we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here is the Eggman
calling in about yes my my cameo
in a Netflix documentary about Malaysian
Airlines flight 370 which I guess is
like one of the top things in the
country right now listen to this
hey I don't know if you mentioned this
on your program yet but yeah you know
that you're in the MH370 the plane that
disappeared a documentary on Netflix
yeah in the second episode
um it's a David backman cameo
I'm sure you know this I'm sure you've
already said that but um it's implying
like you're almost a conspiracy guy
about you know some patterns or
something anyway it was really neat to
see you yeah on this Doc in the middle
of the night when I'm watching TV
shallow brother yeah Shalom to the
Eggman I hope you had a good Purim
listen
um I am probably tomorrow or the day
after gonna do a full segment about my
appearance in that documentary where
they absolutely make me sound like a
conspiracy theorist
by using a clip in which I am debunking
a conspiracy theory now I'm also not
going to blame anybody by by myself but
myself for what happened and I'm going
to explain all of this tomorrow but I am
not happy with the way in which I was
included in that I now know what I did
wrong
um a contract lawyer reached out to me
and we exchanged a couple of emails they
frame me as a conspiracy theorist using
a clip where I'm debunking a conspiracy
let's talk about it tomorrow or
Wednesday I I will tell you what's going
on we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today Tucker Carlson's ex-producer
was worried about their quote dumb
viewers falling for the lies that they
were telling it's a fascinating Peak
behind the curtain a new poll suggests
that Ron desantis's anti-woke Crusade
might actually backfire on him and we
will talk about listen to this every
year daylight savings we talk about the
movement for permanent daylight savings
there's a movement against permanent
daylight savings and it's a different
perspective I'll explain to you what
they believe why we'll evaluate whether
it makes sense and then whatever I'll
take a nap because I'm tired from the
time change so that'll be the plan for
the bonus show I will nap during the
show which will be a new thing uh might
be interesting to some people sign up
for membership at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show
the commercial free audio and video
feeds of the show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money okay
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad all right all right
let's settle down uh and invitations to
member only Town Hall events the next of
which is coming up pretty soon sign up
at joinpakman.com I'll see you then